let's move on to this [ __ ] screenshot
that somebody sent me of what somebody
dm's me this screenshot of Beyonce's
Instagram post she goes look at the
comments the one comma that shows is
from King batch and it says check your
DMS
you idiot oh that has got to be the
saddest comment and I don't you do you
think beyonce has ever checked her dams
no it's not even her that runs that
[ __ ] account no no no she's never
looked at her own social media that if
you said check your DM she probably what
what know it is that maybe he's just
trying to be funny but I doubt there's
no way he's trying to get her in on a
sketch or some [ __ ]
like that's got to be a pretty warped
sense of like how like your position in
Hollywood yeah yeah well I think too
just like he's famous but like he's not
check your DMS to Beyonce famous yeah
well I mean no he is cuz if he if he was
actually that famous his agent would
call her agent yeah but so he is check
your DMV he's not DMing with Beyonce
Fame right he's not getting a response
from Beyonce hey you want to be in this
Instagram sketch hug no I'm gonna keep
just making millions of dollars doing
the stuff that I do I'm just gonna you
know yeah keep being just an icon yeah
so bro ya know have fun with the
Instagram sketches things look I know
that is they sound really cool I've
never even been on Instagram
[Laughter]
Dawg commenting check your DM is uh it's
got to feel bad what do you mean it just
it's this bad man it yeah it just feels
like Tom Brady in the fourth quarter of
the last Super Bowl like you're at the
13 yard line and you got to score it to
maybe tie so true you're just like I'm
so true just accordion yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
it's like just shooting your shot you
know walking up to a sex robot in a club
and just being like hi hi can I buy you
a drink you know it's probably not gonna
happen
you know but you just got to shoot your
shot you got to do it
if I'm in a club ever and I need to be
flirting with a robot kill myself if I'm
ever nervous to float with a real eart
with a robot float with a roburt fro
brat float with a rub it yeah float with
a rivet you respect robots here yeah
yeah respect we respect ribbit rabbits
move it that just means I'm having to
battle some nerds version of a woman in
code and that is gonna be horrible as he
will program her to be insanely
difficult no engineer system just to
level the playing field for all guys
yeah no I don't I can't talk to women so
now none of you none of you can it
doesn't she doesn't and I got all the
cheat code yes XJ 600 doesn't like
muscles she doesn't like fitness she
doesn't like athletic men because they
have too much shouldn't be like mildly
athletic men because they have too much
ego she likes nice guys guys that so in
order to nice guys they're not coming
last anyone that would be horrible in oh
wait
yo here's the here's a fun Beyonce if
you're watching check your DM check your
DN all right I seen some good
you just damned her a meme yeah like you
order like a [ __ ] Jerry post or
something yo yo check your dance I see
some good [ __ ] in there just check those
just so genuine
yeah yo you were like in a meme check it
out
this account um
Venus used you in a meme it's like penis
but would it be yeah did the guys like
funny memes he put you in a meme you put
you in one and it's like it's pretty
good so check it out I thought you'd
like it
yeah for it too yellow well yo Beyonce
what's good match just thought I'd say
what's good you ever send a girl cringe
EDM like that
[Music]
is that Dustin club these are custom
pump these are custom home these are
just all in my bag on my wrists all on
my [ __ ]
what